what uh
is the most
kind of um
memorable powerful ufo encounter report
you've ever heard
just to you pers on a personal level
like this something that was really
powerful well i mentioned the zimbabwe
one that's particularly interesting and
one that actually most people don't know
about but family
driving down the highway two little
girls in the back
open glass
topped car
and
the little girls see
a craft right over their car this is the
middle of the day
on a busy highway
the mother sees it
nobody can
they look around nobody else seems to
see it so the girls take out their
camera take a picture of it
and then they get home
they look at the picture
there's no craft
but there's a little object
about 30 feet above their
car or so
probably about
three feet across kind of star-shaped
it's not the craft
but it's something else there's
obviously there was something there
and so what were they seeing were they
seeing a projection were they seeing
and why were only they seeing it
and the photograph
was capturing something very different
than we're seeing there's still an
object what can you
give a little bit of context is this
from modern day it's modern day oh yeah
they had a camera i mean okay they had a
cell phone camera and this was like a
five years ago report provided by the
way where's like a central place to
provide a report is this oh there's a
move on but this isn't public i've seen
the picture oh this is something you've
directly interacted with yeah yeah i've
seen the picture so those moments like
that
they captivate your uh
well
it's so different it doesn't fall into
the standard story at all but it also
but in another way it's kind of a
it's a clear enunciation of this notion
that when people see events they don't
all see the same thing now we've heard
this about like traffic accidents
different people will see the color of
the car differently or the chain of
events differently and just tells you
that memory isn't anywhere near what we
think it is but
the issue around these so-called ufo
reports is that
the same people will see a very
different thing almost as if whatever it
is is projecting
a is projecting something into the mind
rather than it being real right rather
than being a real manifestation
you know material in front of you it's
actually almost some sort of an altered
reality that is imposed on you i mean
you know i think
the company meta
and all the virtual reality companies
would love to have something like that
right well you don't have to actually
wear something on your face
yes to experience a virtual reality what
happens if you could just project it
well that's the fundamental question
from an alien perspective
when you look at it or as we humans look
at ants
how does this perception system operate
so not only how does this thing's mind
operate how does the human mind operate
but how does it their perception system
operate so that we can like
stimulate the perception system
properly to get them to think certain
things and so uh you know
that's a really important question
humans think that um
you know the only way to communicate is
in like 3d or 4d
space time there's physical objects or
maybe you write things into some kind of
language but there could be just uh
so much
more
richness in how you can communicate and
so from an alien perspective where
somebody has much greater technological
capabilities you have to figure out how
do i use the skills i have
to stimulate
uh the human the limited humans right
well i mean let's take the ants exam
again as an example let's say that you
wanted to
make ants practical
you wanted to use them for something
right you wanted to use them as a form
of biological robot now darpa and other
uh people have been trying to
use insects for you know and to turn
them into biological robots but if you
wanted to
you would have to interact with their
sense of smell
right their pheromone system that they
use to
interact with each other
so you would either create those
molecules to talk to them to make them
do not say talk to them as if they're
intelligent but talk to them to
manipulate them in ways that you want
or if you were
advanced enough you would
use some sort of electromagnetic or
other
means to stimulate their neurons in ways
that would accomplish the same goal
as the pheromones but by doing it in a
sort of a tele-factoring way
so let's say you wanted to tell a factor
with humans
you would
interact with them and this is again
this is a technology which you could
imagine possible
you could tell a factor information into
the sensory system of a human
right but then
each human is a little bit different so
either you know enough about them to
tailor it to that individual or you just
basically take advantage of whatever the
sensory net is that that individual has
so if you happen to be
good at sound or you happen to be a very
visually inclined individual
then maybe the sensory information that
you get
that's most effective
in terms of transmitting information
would come through that portal
i think the aliens would need to figure
out that humans value physical
consistency so we've discovered physics
so we want
our perception to make sense maybe they
don't they haven't you know that's not
an obvious fact of perception that
you have to figure out what kind of
things are humans used to observing in
this particular environment of earth
and how do we stimulate the perception
system
in a way that's uh not anomalous or not
too doesn't cross the threshold of just
like well that's way too weird right so
they have to i mean that's not obvious
that that should be important
you know maybe you want to err on the
side of uh
anomaly like lean into the weirdness so
communication is complicated yeah well
that's why i always i always find this
issue of people talking about the
so-called grays
as interesting because
it it is related to what you're saying
they're different enough
but they're not so different as to be
scary right they're not venom dripping
fangs
right they're different enough
but they they all it's also like they're
they're what you could imagine us
becoming in some distant future so is
that a purposeful representation
i i don't know i mean i don't believe in
the grays for instance but
i believe that people think that they
see it
so if we're talking about a
communication strategy that says
you know we're we're like you but not
the same as you
this might be a manifestation that you
that you represent
in terms of a communication strategy
you